Imagínate que vas al mercado a conseguir
un poco de fruta fresca.
En el momento en que vas a pagar te das cuenta
de que al cliente que atendieron antes
compró 5 manzanas y 4 naranjas por 10 pesos,
mientras que tú compras 5 manzanas y 5 naranjas
por 11 pesos.
Pregunta.
¿Podemos encontrar el precio de cada manzana
y de cada naranja
resolviendo un sistema
de ecuaciones lineales con dos incógnitas?
Si es así,
¿cuál es la solución?
Si no es posible,
¿cuál es la razón de que no se pueda?
Y bueno, para resolver esta pregunta,
lo que se me ocurre que hagamos primero
es nombrar a nuestras variables.
Así que voy a decir que sea
"x" igual al precio de las manzanas,
el precio de las manzanas
es lo mismo que "x"
y por otra parte voy a decir que
"y" es igual al precio de las naranjas...
al precio de las naranjas...
Muy bien, y ahora vamos a intentar escribir
con ecuaciones estos dos datos que yo tengo.
El primer dato que tengo
es que el cliente anterior
le cobraron 10 pesos
por 5 manzanas y 4 naranjas
es decir que 5 porque son 5 manzanas,
por el precio que vale cada una de las manzanas,
5 por "x", más 4 por el precio de lo que vale
cada una de las naranjas,
es decir "y", esto tiene que ser iguala 10 pesos,
"5x" más "4y" tiene que ser igual a 10 pesos,
eso es lo que nos dice
nuestro primer dato,
ahora, a mi me cobraron 11 pesos
por 5 manzanas y 5 naranjas,
entonces 5 por el precio de lo que vale
cada una de las manzanas y recuerda,
que "x" es el precio
de lo que vale 1 manzana,
por lo tanto "5x" es el precio
de lo que valen las 5 manzanas,
más 5 por "y", es decir, 5 naranjas por el precio de
lo que vale cada una de las naranjas,
esto me tiene que dar igual a 11 pesos,
esto me dice que es igual a 11 pesos.
Y bueno, ahora lo que nos preguntan es
¿si podemos resolver este sistema de ecuaciones?
y si es posible,
¿cuál es la solución?
y si no,
¿cuál es la razón de que no se pueda resolver?
Ahora date cuenta que a mi me parece
que sí tiene solución,
porque tenemos distintos coeficientes para "x"
y para "y" en las dos ecuaciones,
si tuviéramos los mismos coeficientes
para "x" y para "y",
luego luego podemos concluir que no,
además la otra cosa por la cual me suena que sí tiene solución, es porque una no es múltiplo de la otra,
si me tomo una de las dos ecuaciones y la multiplico por cualquier constante, nunca me va a dar la otra,
entonces parece ser que este
sistema de ecuaciones si tiene solución.
Ahora, para encontrar la solución lo que voy a hacer
es multiplicar por menos la ecuación de abajo,
entonces éste me queda
"-5x" menos "5y" y -11.
Y ahora voy a sumar las dos ecuaciones para resolverlas por el método de suma y resta o de eliminación,
así que vamos a sumar la parte izquierda
de estas dos ecuaciones
y la parte derecha
de esas dos ecuaciones,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
"5x" menos "5x",
estas dos se van,
se cancelan, perfecto,
después me queda, "4y" menos "5y"
esto es lo mismo que "-y"
y del lado derecho me va a quedar que 10 menos 11, esto es lo mismo que -1.
Y ahora ya tengo que "-y" es igual a -1
y de aquí si multiplico ambos lados por -1,
me va a quedar que "y" es igual a 1, perfecto,
¿y que era "y"?
¡Claro! el precio de las naranjas, es decir
que cada una de las naranjas me costó 1 peso.
Ahora no hay que olvidar sacar el precio de las manzanas y para sacar el precio de las manzanas
voy a sustituir el valor de "y" en la primera ecuación
y tengo que "5x" más 4 por "y",
pero "y" vale 1 entonces voy a poner más 4 por 1,
esto es lo mismo que 10,
esto tiene que ser igual a 10 y estoy sustituyendo
el precio de cada una de las naranjas,
que ya lo sé, vale 1 peso.
Y de aquí obtengo que 4 por 1 es 4,
así que voy a restar 4 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
así que me va a quedar...
y déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla,
porque estos dos se van a eliminar...
me va a quedar, "5x" es igual a 6,
"5x" y del otro lado me va a quedar 10 menos 4,
lo cual es 6.
Y ahora para obtener el valor de "x" voy a dividir todo entre 6, todo entre 6 y así voy a obtener el valor de "x"
y... Oh, no, no, no, no, no, espera, espera, espera...
no es entre 6 es entre 5,
mi cerebro está
bastante dormido todavía...
¡Perdón! era entre 5
para sacar el valor de "x",
de tal manera, que 5 entre 5 se van
y solamente me queda que "x" es igual a 6/5...
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla para escribirlo...
"x" es igual a 6/5,
que por cierto esto es lo mismo que 1 entero 1/5,
que por cierto esto es lo mismo que 1.20,
es decir que cada manzana
costó 1 peso con 20 centavos...
1 peso con 20 centavos,
1.20 de peso.
Y bueno, la respuesta es que sí,
sí podemos encontrar la solución.